hey david you've been covering some of
trump's 2021 rallies do you think his
2021 rallies will be as effective as
they were
in 2016. so couple different things the
point of the 2021 trump rallies is very
different than 2016. in 2016 trump
was running for president um in 2020
trump was running for president the
rallies were about vote for me
sometimes begrudgingly he would say okay
maybe vote for some of these
senatorial or congressional candidates
that came out as well but
basically it was vote for me right now
although we can
imagine that the point of the trump
rally from last week or the one you know
whatever the next one's going to be
it's sort of to set up a 2024 run
really it's something else it's one to
feed trump's ego which has been
significantly damaged by being kicked
out of the white house by joe biden so
it's an emotional thing for donald trump
number two
it is setting up the grift of donating
money to the
the pack or however they're organized
where trump will decide who are the good
republicans not the rhinos worthy of my
support of your support
that's going to be a part of it and then
three it will be to still be the decider
but less as a candidate and more is the
person that will
give what he considers to be a very
valuable endorsement to 2022
candidates and um there's a couple
differences also between now and 2016 in
terms of trump's perception in 2016
trump was basically
sort of eccentric celebrity and there
were lots of people who just wanted to
be in close contact with trump and that
drove interest in trump in 2015 2016
and um made the rallies maybe more
powerful than they're going to be
right now um there is more trump fatigue
at this point and in addition to that
there are also more people who are kind
of over the celebrity aspect of trump
and um i mean listen if you're at this
point if you're
under 30 i would say if you're under 26
you really see trump more as that
president guy who's no longer president
than as a real estate mogul in the 80s
in new york city
and there is some sense i have that
again i go back to it because i think
it's so dangerous
ron desantis is a guy who could really
challenge trump
not just in in an electoral sense if it
came to it in 2024 but
he has a lot of the same horrible
authoritarian tendencies as trump but
he's more competent
and he's a better speaker and this makes
him
i believe significantly more dangerous
the problem for some
in some sense for republicans is that
for now they're
stuck with trump as a leader whether
they want him or not
until someone else surfaces so even
though we can pull republicans right now
and
you know 70 say they'd vote trump again
30 say they wouldn't
that 30 percent has not coalesced around
anyone in particular
and if and until that happens trump
trump's control of the republican party
is his for the taking
he will never let go of power he will
he'll bring down
the ship with him and in a sense he did
right i mean the republican party lost
the house in 2018
the senate in 2020 the white house in
2020 under trump
trump sees himself as great for the
party he talks about his endorsements
are worth so much etc so
trump will destroy the party if it's up
to him will someone remove him from that
position of power
and in the end the rallies are going to
be more of a revenue generating activity
and a way to placate trump's broken ego
than they are at least in 2021
electorally significant for donald trump
that's my sense if you see the modern
trump rally is something different
then let me know we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
how do you get the bonus show it's so
easy you just sign up at jointpakman.com
that is it
sign up at joinpakman.com use the coupon
code better21 if you would like
and we will see you in mere seconds on
today's bonus show
one of our sponsors today is strategic
voters a new podcast that features
election experts political campaign
strategists and everyday americans
who sit down and discuss the biggest
issues in the u.s
political landscape on the activism side
strategic voters as an organization
aims to encourage people to vote with
the benefit of the country
as a whole in mind instead of just
voting one party
down the ballot if you want to hear some
really different
and interesting opinions and approaches
to voting and viewing policies
give the strategic voters podcast a
listen
the latest two episodes feature rachel
cobb and lana atkinson as guests
i've been listening to it myself i've
been really enjoying it it's very
grassroots and independent which i love
find the strategic voters podcast
on all major podcast platforms and make
sure to follow them
on twitter at strategic voters